so these are two hybrid 3D printed
weapons
this one is known as the fgc9 no one
knows why the man who made these did so
but technology and online designs
allowed him to produce these potentially
deadly weapons from the comfort of his
own home
this one fires conventional Factory
ammunition
so it's every bit as lethal as any other
gun firing that ammunition the other one
is designed apparently to fire adaptive
blanks which are more variable in
performance but certainly capable of
penetrating
six to eight inches into human flesh
David Biddle Portman a forklift truck
driver from Birmingham told police he
had an interest in the mechanics of guns
after they discovered these assault
rifles in his bedroom wardrobe he'd used
a 3D printer to make solid components
from a digital file and assembled them
police tested the firearms and found
they were capable of firing ammunition
anyone who was curious enough to attempt
or to conspire to produce such a weapon
they do well to take lessons from the
sentence has been handed out to
um to Portman today
and hopefully that will send the message
that the police and the courts take
these matters really really seriously
Biddle Portman added seal parts for key
components that could not be made from
plastic police also found bullets in his
toolbox
Sky News investigation found that 3D
printed gun designs could easily be
found online and in the US a mainly
American online community has sprung up
showcasing their creations
but it's a growing problem for the UK
too at this stage we're looking at 3D
printed Farms as an emerging threat it's
fair to say that we've seen a
significant increase in both their
design production and recoveries in the
last 12 to 18 months the prosecution of
Biddle Portman is one of the first in
the UK for making viable 3D printed
weapons but police still don't know what
he intended to do with them
Lisa Dowd Sky News Birmingham